on reste aux etats unis les événements
du capitole sont encore dans tous les
esprits près d'un an après alors qu'une
commission d' enquête parlementaire
poursuit ses investigations en ciblant
donald trump est bien ce dernier a
annoncé la tenue d'une conférence de
presse 6 janvier prochain un an jour
pour jour après les violences qui se
sont produites à washington on en parle
tout de suite avec notre correspondant
aux états unis thomas boni
thomas bonsoir alors pourquoi donald
trump peut-il prendre la parole en ce
jour particulier
et bien parce qu'il contexte il conteste
le narratif qui est exposée dans les
principaux médias américains autour de
cette journée du 6 janvier on sait aussi
qu'un certain nombre de ses proches ont
refusé de se rendre à des auditions de
cette commission d' enquête
parlementaire et cette semaine donald
trump a même saisi la cour suprême des
états unis pour demander à ce qu'elle
bloque le transfert de ces documents
datant de l'époque où il était à la
maison blanche à destination de cette
commission d'enquêté ping donald trump a
organisé une conférence de presse ce
sera le 6 janvier prochain à mar à lago
en floride il devrait répéter les
messages qu'il martèle depuis maintenant
des mois à savoir qu'elle estime que
cette commission denquête et partisane
et donc biaisé écoutez un extrait du
communiqué publié par donald trump
pourquoi le comité des politiciens
partisans nanquette in pas sur les
causes de la manifestation du 6 janvier
à savoir l'élection truquée de 2020 est
ce que quelqu'un a remarqué qu'ils
veulent se tenir le plus éloigné
possible de ce sujet les chiffres ne
vont pas dans leur sens où même son
approche la seule chose qu'ils peuvent
faire c'est de ne pas en parler
alors conséquences ou pas de cette
conférence de presse qui va être
organisé par donald trump la maison
blanche a annoncé depuis que joe biden
aussi allé prendre la parole le 6
janvier prochain on ne sait pas encore
exactement sous quelle forme ce qu'on
sait en revanche c'est que les
démocrates du congrès prévoit une
journée spéciale pour l'occasion malgré
le fait est qu'il n'y ait pas de travaux
parlementaires prévues à l'agenda pour
le 6 janvier les démocrates autour de
nancy pelosi ont déjà un programme
spécifiquement prévu pour cette journée
avec notamment des veillées une veillée
de prière et des prises de parole sous
la forme de témoignage de parlementaires
qui était au capitole le 6 janvier
dernier
merci beaucoup et thomas bonnet pour
toutes ces précisions en direct de
washington